dentro faccio sempre l'intro di merda io
facciamo un intro di merda
celo celo celo da intro celo celo
aspetta questa è abbastanza di merda
cioè nel senso rende vero fede porca
[ __ ] che si pettina con le bombe a mano
c'è chi si pettina con i pettini insomma
io c'ho il mio porca [ __ ] che casini
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video
sono vari generi ed oggi siamo tornati
su happy wings che trenta ragazzi siamo
al 93esimo episodio ogni domenica che
passa ci avviciniamo al 100
probabilmente esploderà il mondo quando
arriveremo al centesimo episodio non lo
so se veramente nero che sta cavalcando
un pony cioè non è razzismo però
spiegatemelo a questa con voglio capire
non ho capito ma quindi io posso cliccar
e le cose mi escono le cose tipo questo
non funziona funziona solo scherzando
filing swords ha così sparo direttamente
le celebri io in te sto facendo uno
sword trovo senza muovere la mano
fantastico siamo finiti i saldi da
trussardi
ma la ragazza quantistici di delle donne
cos'è quella roba lì non importa perché
manca solo questo
babbo stai tranquillo stai proprio calmo
rifacciamo che è meglio perché veramente
non ho capito una mazza per tratto se
lancio le spade basta funzionano tanto
che spari sono e chan delle dentature
stupidissime picchia quanta strage per
uno spa da solo e ti piace essere
sculacciata è baby rpg carpice va beh
non ci credo mai che funziona veramente
non va bene marco livello il livello
della vita ma fatemelo votare otto
stelle c'è ma quanto è figo sponge boy
complimenti sponge poi per aver fatto
sto livello epico just do it a ma questa
volta fa anno diverso ne hanno fatto un
altro di jobs 2 bello complimenti
magari visto che il muro invisibile ma
magari metterla un'insegna del tipo
attenzione muro invisibile no che ci si
muove col chiamo tranquillamente la
faccia sopra tranquilli piano seriamente
adesso bravo dato che ebbe come attiva
ce la fai port camino dai o che almeno
tu vai salvati uovo si muovo se l'uomo
eccolo lì il mio uomo è colori dove
l'altro [ __ ] ecco è rimasto sul
seggiolino però vabbè ho vinto con gli
occhi non so come però i ragazzi a
vincere io il suo livello di che
impossibile come come fosse come aera
ero rimasto vivo quel padre va bene
spende in questo 720 e questa roma deve
andare avanti col ma veramente eva belli
li prendi zio li prendi ecco visto visto
che le riprese
ecco io oddio no ragazzi un piede mi ha
appena salvato la vita non so se vi
rendete conto come come è stato
possibile questa conoso ecco infatti non
ci saranno sempre i tuoi piedi a
proteggerti ricordatelo
che succede paga il suo arrivato col
cuore importante arrivarci col cuore
grazie come faccio a fare story va
quindi io devo resistere facilmente fino
alla pa come fanno andare avanti è la
madonna manco fosse un trampolino come
questa cosa o caso se va prezzi
di rocco sera la roma di
sta cosa non lo capì addio ragazzi
abbiamo un nuovo supereroe in città che
supera di gran lunga superman e batman
sto cazzo man tutti quanti si chiama al
pullman esiste l'arpione me lo faccio lo
faccio io perché vedo vedo che sei ben
disposta a fare l'arpione man
ragazzi io sto livello non lo finirò mai
ve lo dico come minchia faccia
sopravvivere ma mi demoliscono ogni tre
secondi
porca eva neanche partire però c'è meno
sono andato a prendere io l'urp no
perché non mi stava colpendo quindi sono
andato io apprendano giusto dai dai dai
dai
si no
questa è considerabile come vittorie
ragazzi no perché mi manca un millimetro
e arrivò solo che ciò gli arpioni nel
culo questo potrebbe essere un problema
tecnico di ri arkaios breakdown dall
ultimo episodio volevo questo
maledizione non l'hanno ancora fatto non
ci sono regole nella d'abilità più in
one verde pichi l'arbitro di
squalificano a meno che non ti veda
solca questa comunque non era un
archivio però come premio vinto un
tavolo nell'anno che è sempre meglio di
un pugno in un occhio porta 5 stelle se
sei giorni cena quindi 5 stelle e può
lottare solo john cena quindi john cena
sta dalla parte di beppe grillo la
smetto ragazzi trasmettono credo sia una
sorta di malattia questa di dire battute
idiote però prima o poi smetterò ve lo
giuro faccio del mio meglio
oltre 64 un secolo che non ne faccio uno
decente vero non sarà questa la volta
buona
non ci avevo dubbi ai frate forza che
non è ancora sì ma come casse possibile
o lanciata al km è tornato sempre su ma
basta ma come qualsiasi cosa faccio la
finire su morte impossibile no no fin 9
già meglio già meglio
madonna che cestista ragazzi minchia
walterone che la versione cinese di
volte guai ss3 è un cellulare intendi no
ecco noi non è assolutamente un
cellulare per sembra più un assorbente
per questa roba a si alzano sti cosi
fantastico promessa che dio sta cadendo
aiuta me ma devo tipo strisciare sulle
cose così fantastico bello sto salto
complimenti
chi è quello cioè gesù c'è un tipo no
vabbè non l'ho preso tanto vinco uguale
sono convintissimo ottima st vittoria
frate cosa stai facendo no dai dai dai
dai dai
da bravo allora c'erano così mi chiamano
usato il poco anche una volta ciao zio
ma era era uno zio era una zia non è che
visto chi era avrò dei grazie della
moneta vado a comprarmi le caramelle
buone software è una trappola di questa
edizone l'enigmista hai solo pochi
secondi per scappare alla mia trappola
c'è solo un modo per scappare se non
scappi prima del tempo morirai tanti
auguri solo perfetto quanto tempo è una
domanda che non necessita più di
risposta ragazza cosa devo fare spiegano
devo staccarmi da questa cosa mi aspetta
però serve la musica di saw l'enigmista
senza staccate staccate uomo e staccati
ma inizia dai frate dai su una e due
come ho fatto a sopravvivere non lo so
va bene ho rimesso solo una gamba come
in sol sul serio anche in soci mettono
una gamba del challenge questa proprio
na na na challenge generale nel senso
proprio non è neanche spiegato che cos'è
e io la vinco quasi allora fermi un
attimo
[Musica]
cioè il tasto mi piace ragazzi dovete
andarci sopra proprio sopra il tasto e
poi dovete premere il mouse finché non
si sfonda al mouse sul mi piace se
proprio deve esplodere
va bene io sono qui e ora vuoi sapere
devono fare la madonna wingardium
leviosa ecco ad acer avanti il mingardi
un leviosa fa cadere le bottiglie
esposte ai camion wingardium sua madre
vicar di un sei grasso wingardium sei
stupido mingardi hanno vinto non c'è
bisogno di votarlo meno male perché gli
avrei dato una stella ammentos più koch
ma cosa non esplode bellissimo tra la
settimana scorsa con la coca cola in
gelatina e sto livello qua non so quale
dei due possa essere meglio che è quanta
coca cola ce l'ha dentro spiegano le va
bene
un livello che ha aumentato la mia
autostima di tantissime cioè non vi
sentite più pieni di vita dopo questo
ragazzo li passiamo un paio di miei
livelli visto che è un secolo che non
faccio livelli miei fi.gi lampada oro
che vuol dire quella è una lampada
quella è una offesa zio andiamo con le
lampade che li vedevo volteggiare
fantastico dai tipi che cosa serve un
cestino ragazzi c'è spiegatemelo il
cesvi l'utilità del cestino la voglio
sapere ok stato distrutto
sono ancora vivo no sono morto così sono
morto annusando mi piedi poi prefetto
vai
ci siamo stavolta sono vivo fotte sega
ok dai vari suo livello
ditemi voi quando è finito e per carità
di dio
oddio la pioggia dei sessi non la vedevo
tifo da da sei anni su è più il
fantastico dove sto ragazzo c'entrano
perché no non mi puoi far questo non ha
neanche più le braccia per trascinarmi
da adesso ci arrivi ti ammazzo la fase
non ci arrivi ti ammazzo la famiglia
noah di la devi andare vai o non ci
voglio credere ma veramente ma che cazzo
di url e niente sono morto a vela ho
vinto
cioè almeno il coso ha vinto fa vj steps
liszt
questo è il mio primo livello non
schifoso ha quindi tu sei già giudicato
perfetto qualche urto green slim please
ok facciamolo ciò che ci sono gli
arpioni zio caschi malissimo
dove devo andare spiegano cipro 6 calmo
dopo devi stare calmo nella vita fatti
una tisana la madonna parkour da morti
[Musica]
coraggio uomo non li so fare io livelli
di equity a comprimere veramente
ultimamente sono un genio perfetto come
anche perché non lo giuro che se morivo
anche stavolta a due metri dalla fine mi
incazzavo di brutto prima erano anche
meno di due metri lo stai facendo svezia
libera la rai finito niente lui
pedalabili si tiene in forma pazienza
ecco allora gazzoli spero che ha visto
vi sia piaciuto cosi subito piaciuta un
commento è un mi piace che dovete
sfondarlo anche per aiutarmi nel fare i
livelli quelli dove rimango prima di
toccare il traguardo è la mia vita perde
di significato anche a base di facebook
con il v8 atene iscrizione socialisti
fischiati ci vediamo al prossimo video
ragazzi